قال حاكم القرم الموالي لروسيا انه تم
اسقاط سته مسيرات اوكرانيه في مناطق
مختلفه من جهتها افادت الاداره العسكريه
في غربي اوكرانيا بان انفجارات دوت في
المدينه بتزامن مع عمل الدفاعات الجويه
على اسقاط مسيارات مفخخه كما تحدثت
السلطات اوديسا عن التعرض لهجوم ارهابي
للمسيرات روسيه هجوميه واشارت الاداره
العسكريه في كييف الى ان الدفاعات الجويه
تتعامل مع هجمه معاديه بطائرات مسيره
واتهمت الاداره العسكريه في خاركيب القوات
الروسيه بقصف المدينه
مراسله في ميكولايز في المقابل تامر
السلطات الاوكرانيه تتحدث عن هجوم روسيه
على عده مناطق في اوكرانيا قربنا من
المشهد هناك
بالفعل سهام قبل قليل تحدث الرئيس
الاوكراني على صفحته في تيليجرام عن ان
الليله الماضيه كانت عصيبه على المدنيين
في كييف وعديد المقاطعات
الجنوبيه القوات الجويه الاوكرانيه تحدثت
عن اكثر من 30 هجوما بمسيره هجوميه روسيه
من نوع شاهد اطلقت باتجاه كييفوا
لايف حيث نتواجد وفضلا عن مقاطعات اخرى في
الجنوب الاوكراني الذي يشهد حاله كبيره من
التسخين بين القوات الاوكرانيه والروسيه
على واقع ما يقال عن هجوم مضاد وشيك مرتقب
للقوات الاوكرانيه القوات الجويه
الاوكرانيه تحدثت عن الاحباط الهجوم
المذكور فجر هذا اليوم وقالت بان الدفاعات
الجويه تمكنت من اسقاط كامل المسيرات التي
اطلقت من الاتجاه الشمالي
والجنوبي واشارت الى ان تلك المسيرات كانت
تهدف الى ضرب البنيه التحتيه الحيويه
بالاضافه الى
المنشات العسكريه وفي الحقيقه نادرا ما
تتحدث السلطات العسكريه الاوكرانيه عن
استهداف روسيا للمنشات العسكريه باعتبارها
منشات حساسه لكن اليوم تقول القوات الجويه
الاوكرانيه بان هذا الهجوم كان يستهدف
بشكل مباشر المنشات العسكريه
الاوكرانيه هنا في ميكولايد اعلن عمده
المقاطعه عن اسقاط اربعه من تلك المسيرات
وتحدث عن استمرار القصف المدفعي الثقيل
على
المناطق الساحليه من المقاطعه المطله على
البحر الاسود والتي تتواصل فيها عمليات
القصف والحديث هناك عن تضرر كبير في
البنيه التحتيه وفي منازل المدنيين
والحديث ايضا عن جرحى في خرسون القريبه من
هنا والمغلقه بقرار من السلطات الاوكرانيه
على واقع قصف لا يهدا بين القوات
الاوكرانيه والروسيه تحدث عمده المقاطعه
صباح هذا اليوم عن اكثر من ثمانين هجوما
بالمدفعيه الثقيله وبمختلف انواع الذخيره
في الح هو تحدث عن جرحى في صفوف المدنيين
واشار الى ان القصف لم يتكتب فقط على قلب
المدينه وانما على طول خط المواجهه بين
القوات الاوكرانيه والروسيه لا سيما عند
ضفتي نهر دنيبر في المقاطعه الحديث عن ان
القوات الاوكرانيه تكثف من قصفها هناك
لمواقع تركز القوات الروسيه بالمدفعيه
الثقيله
والحديث ايضا عن ما تقوم به القوات
الروسيه هناك من عمل حواجز مائيه على نهر
دنيبر عند الضفه التي تتواجد فيها تحسبا
من اي تقدم للقوات الاوكرانيه ونهايتنا
الحديث
الاتهامات التي اطلقت صباحا من قبل الجانب
الروسي عن احباط الهجوم المذكور السلطات
الاوكرانيه في كييف لم تعلق حتى هذه
اللحظه لكن طالما اكدت بانها لا تستهدف
على عمق الروسي وانما تسعى الى استهداف
المناطق المواقع التي تسيطر عليها القوات
الروسيه داخل الاراضي الاوكرانيه
من نيكولايف شكرا لك